today's protagonist was hailed by the
courts of 18th century europe as an
infallible eye surgeon able to restore
sight to hundreds of patients thanks to
his miraculous cures also he said many
of his contemporary colleagues
considered him to be the quintessential
quack doctor little more than a con man
with a scalpel legendary writer samuel
johnson who had the fortune to meet the
oculus described him as the most
ignorant man i ever knew he was an
instance of how far impudence will carry
ignorance and peter william hogarth
included his likeness in the engraving
the undertaker arms a gallery of the
most dangerous healers of the time
despite these rather grandiose
connections our man's name is most
infamously linked to that of a composer
he was in fact the oculus who blinded
and possibly killed a johann sebastian
bark this is the story of chevalier john
taylor optomata pontifical imperial and
royal
[Music]
john taylor was born in norwich england
on august 16 1703 into a family of
medical professionals his mother was an
apothecary while his father was a
respected surgeon medicine ran deep in
taylor's blood four generations before
john had been doctors or surgeons he
would become an oculus and so would his
son grandson and great-grandson but
john's father did not have time to
impart any medical wisdom on our
protagonist as he died when the boy was
just six the tiny tailor took it upon
himself to help his mother behind the
apothecary's counter so that they could
provide for his two younger brothers
john continued his education in norwich
aiming to become a doctor like his late
father at the age of 19 he was described
in an anonymous 1761 biography as a
handsome spruce doctor there was not a
more gumly personage in all of norfolk
the description was late corroborated by
john's grandson also called john the
chevalier was a tall handsome man and a
great favorite with the ladies he was
much addicted to splendor in dress and
to an expensive style of domestic
expenditure sometime in 1721 the teenage
flamboyant budding doctor was summoned
by a rich quaker named ebenezer to treat
his colleague but the young wife of the
patient tabitha happened to cast a
favory lear at john in medical terms she
rather had the hot spin a silent
exchange of glances opens the congress
to a more substantial intercourse
unfortunately ebenezer walked in on john
and tabitha during said substantial
intercourse quick of limbs and brains
john scrambled out of bed holding a pen
knife in his hands not for self-defense
but to support the lamest of excuses he
was merely treating tabitha to remove
the corns from her feet as ebenezer
processed this pile of steamy manure
john sprinted out of the bedroom he
bolted so fast and so far that he left
norwich and continued running until
london where he resumed his medical
studies taylor studied at st thomas
hospital under surgeons william
chesselden and john de saglier who
advised him to specialize in eye surgery
according to chesterton taylor was a
diligent student who passed his
examinations with all becoming exactness
the young graduate was appointed chief
surgeon in a norwich hospital where he
first tried his hand at lithotomies or
the removal of gallstones but he soon
directed his interest towards
ophthalmology establishing a good
reputation as a counter of cataracts
allow me to clarify here couching was an
old method to treat cataracts which are
cloudy areas in the lens of the eye
which impair the patient's vision
couching consisted in perforating the
patient size outer layer or cornea with
a sharp hooked needle by using this
implement the surgeon would then
displace the lens of the eye by pushing
it downwards and backwards this
procedure basically shifted the cataract
away from the pupil partially restoring
vision medical literature reassures this
that this operation was relatively
painless but between you and me i'd
never allow this dude to come near my
eyes with a sharp hook but the good folk
of nourish were apparently steelier than
me and dozens of patients had their
sight restored by a young doctor
taylor's experience allowed him to
author his first medical treatise an
account of the mechanism of the eye
published in 1727 the preface of this
book first mentions what will become
taylor's personal motto cui sum v tam
dat latin for who gives sight gives life
surely an ambitious statement but that's
in line with his character not happy
with the limitations of the english
language taylor even coined a new term
to refer to himself combining the greek
words for i and physician optomata
in that same year 1727 taylor left
norwich setting out on a long tour of
britain ireland and continental europe
it's not clear why he decided to leave
his hometown and embark on such a tour
according to author dr george coates it
was common at the time for oculus to
move constantly to avoid the ire of
their patients the couching procedure
did restore sight but improvement was
often only temporary thus surgeons left
town before the negative end results
became obvious we know from other
sources that taylor had the habit of
overselling his skills over promising
miraculous results in lengthy orations
before obscuring his patient's corneas
it's logical then that he preferred to
practice his craft as an itinerant
oculus cashing in and leaving town while
still a hero and so it was that
opthalmata taylor toured extensively
through the british isles until 1733
before crossing the channel into france
visiting also holland and switzerland
his tactic of getting the heck out of
there at the right time seemed to work
as his movements were preceded by
favorable newspaper articles or even
endorsements by celebrities of the time
such as swiss physician and poet albert
von haler taylor's reputation within the
medical community continued to grow and
in 1734 in 1735 he received four
honorary medical doctorates from
universities in france switzerland and
cologne in modern-day germany in 1736
our doctor returned to london his fame
such that he was appointed royal oculus
by king george ii surely this level of
fame was met by adequate compensation
but john seemed to have a talent for
squandering all of his earnings getting
into debt and not paying suppliers for
example in 1736 he was sued by one mrs
nugent in london as he lodged his
convalescing patients in nugent's house
but failed to settle the bill later in
1736 he crossed the channel again either
pursuing more fame and fortune or
escaping creditors after a brief stay in
paris taylor visited berlin a local
newspaper at the time reported the
taylor was so deep in debt that he had
to flee his residence at night and
without a lantern following more travel
across the german land and france they
across the pyrenees and arrived in
madrid in october 1737. for the
following five years he continued to
perform surgery in the iberian peninsula
amassing more praise and even meeting
philip the fifth of spain and john the
fifth portugal by 1742 he styled himself
john taylor esquire a cultist to the
king a knight of the order of portugal
doctor of the physic he later wrote to
have celebrated his greatest trials
between madrid and lisbon and yet the
great oculus still couldn't keep still
between 1742 and 1749 he launched
another tour of the british isles
garnering plenty of favorable press
along the way journalist h cross grove
wrote in 1742 i was an eyewitness to his
restoring to sight two persons at my
house on thursday last further 12
patients signed a document testing that
dr john taylor oculus to the king
recovered our perfect sight after having
entirely lost it many years
sure positive reviews from swiss poets
journalists and patients didn't do any
harm but dr taylor had a knack for what
we today call marketing as a good
marketer he understood that he needed
support from the true influences of the
time the aristocracy for his next tour
of europe his strategy would be to
impress local nobility with live
demonstrations of his scientific
knowledge and surgical prowess served
with a copious topping of extravagant
elegance and flair in july of 1749
taylor left london reaching the hague
early in august he traveled with a
personalized carriage decorated with
pictures of eyes and emblazoned with his
motto who gives sight gives life he was
surrounded by a platoon of livery
lackeys who spread the word of taylor's
medical miracles already on august the
18th a local paper reported how the
oculus had impressed the prince and
princess of orange by restoring the
sight of their groom of the chambers the
friendly journalist even reported that
he fitted a blind man with an artificial
eyeball of his own invention with the
aid of which the man is once again able
to see to a certain extent and even to
read six days later the ruling prince
and princess conferred on him the title
of their oculus in ordinary with the
backing of such influences he certainly
was trending taylor moved to amsterdam
in september where an overenthusiastic
journal claimed that he had restored
sight to more than 440 persons without
any accident having befallen a single
one taylor had influencers and reviewers
on his side and he was set to face a
radiant future but that's when the
experts chimed in those bloody spore
sports the inspector of the medical
faculty in amsterdam issued a statement
claiming that the operations undertaken
by taylor had been fruitless resulting
in nothing but sad results by the end of
the month the foster chase etung a
newspaper previously favorable to taylor
dealt the final blow to his reputation
the article reported that all the
favorable testimonials flaunted by the
occultist had actually been bought for
cash having heard there's an angry mob
assembled under his lodgings it's not
clear if they carried torches and
pitchforks but the article claims they
were ready to attack the eye doctor
luckily for him taylor was able to
sneakily evade the siege displaying an
enviable amount of cheek the ops almata
promptly sued the dutch medical faculty
for libel taylor complemented the
lawsuit by spinning some favorable pr on
october 14 1749 a newspaper in cologne
published a heartfelt defense of our
good eye doctor victim of vicious
attacks by ignorant and envious rivals
the trick must have worked as two months
later taylor and his entourage entered
cologne for another tour of tranquil
talks demonstrations and miraculous
surgery the german states welcomed the
english oculus with open arms it seems
by this time he had started introducing
himself as chevalier this is an
aristocratic title meaning knight it is
disputed whether he actually deserved
such title although taylor did claim to
have been knighted by the king of
portugal he also had a diamond-studded
cross bequeathed by the monarch to prove
it in january 1750 taylor operated on
one hair hurt bearing the fancy title of
counsellor of the high court of justice
to his syrian highness the land grave of
hess darmstadt according to a newspaper
article dr taylor restored the
councillor's site without the least
accident curiously the paper was fosiche
setung the same publication which had
utterly cancelled and destroyed our
friend just a few weeks earlier
the german tour continued with a visit
to leipzig on march 27th this was the
place of residence of one of the
greatest composers of all time joanne
sebastian bark now well into his 60s
bark's vision had been steadily
worsening the exact diagnosis is not
clear according to dr richard zieger's
department of ophthalmology university
of amsterdam bark likely suffered from
myopia and cataracts the musician was
worried by the idea of completely losing
his sight advised by his friends he
agreed to seek treatment from the
celebrity itinerant ophthalmic taylor
first operated on the genius composer
sometime between the 28th and 31st of
march 1750 again the exact nature of the
surgery is not known but it most likely
was taylor's standing couching procedure
for cataracts if that was the case buck
was operated on while sitting on a chair
anaesthetics were not commonly used at
the time and oculus sometimes relied on
copious amounts of alcohol or opiates
taylor had another preferred method he
would use a spatula to press the upper
eyelid against the eyeball thus numbing
the nerve endings in the area an
assistant most likely held the musician
firmly in place to avoid sudden jerking
movements after the couching procedure
taylor normally wrapped his patient's
eyes with a tight bandage and prescribed
a course of laxatives and bloodletting
our good friends at vasiche zedong
reported that bark was able to see much
better after the first operation but it
must have been a temporary effect or a
plain lie spun by taylor in fact between
the fifth and the seventh of april
taylor was called to operate on bark a
second time the cobos biographies
indicate that after the second
intervention he was rendered completely
blind fell ill and endured pain in his
eyes these effects are consistent with
many post-operative complications of the
couching procedure such as an eye
hemorrhage or retinal detachment it
seems like taylor had botched both
operations especially the second one not
only was bach unable to perform alright
music but his general health rapidly
declined on july 28 1750 the master of
baroque music succumbed to a stroke
followed by a lethal bout of what was
described as burning fever it was
reported that he suddenly recovered his
vision days before his death but this
could have been a case of charles bonnet
syndrome in which patients experience
complex visual hallucinations so could
it be that chevalier taylor's surgical
procedures may have caused the premature
death of johann sebastian bark well
according to dr ziegers it is unlikely
that bark's burning fever resulted from
surgical complications he does however
point out that the operations
bloodletting and or purgatives would
have weakened him and predisposed him to
new infections
taylor left leipzig on the 8th of april
made a stop in potsdam then headed
towards berlin aiming to impress the
prussian royal court
he didn't while in potsdam he had
operated on two partially blind women
completing the job as in he totally
blinded them news troubled fast and his
royal majesty frederick ii aka frederick
the great took an interest in the case
according to a local paper the king most
graciously issued the order for the said
taylor to leave berlin the sooner the
better so that no other persons who
suffer misfortune with their eyes it was
also reported that frederick most
graciously threatened to string taylor
by the neck should he ever get near his
subject's eyes taylor resurfaced in
dresden in june as usual traveling
faster than bad news in 1751 he was
called to rostock to restore the sight
of the duke of mekelberg schwerin who
suffered from vitis that's inflammation
of the middle layer of the eye not only
did he fail but the duke's personal
physician dr eschenbach found that the
portuguese cross sported by taylor was a
mere piece of jewellery not a badge of
knighthood undeterred the phony
chevalier continued to tour european
capitals from warsaw to saint petersburg
from copenhagen to rome landing in the
eternal city in 1755 taylor had the
chance to impress none other than pope
benedict xiv who actually nobilated him
the now not-so-phony chevalier continued
to meander through europe before
returning to britain in august of 1758
he was reported as staying in the town
of tunbridge well southeast of london
and here is where he may have operated
on another giant of classical music
george frederick handel but let's take
this one with a pinch of salt the only
source for this procedure is a passing
reference in taylor's autobiography and
a poem published in the london chronicle
on august 24th it reads on the recovery
of the site of the celebrated mr handle
by the chevalier taylor in this poem the
muse uterp invokes apollo and the god of
medicine escapists for them to restore
handle sight but apollo replies that
their help is not needed the chevalier
tailor will fix handel's eyes by all
accounts the composer's site continued
to worsen alongside his general health
and he died on april 13 1759. it's not
clear if taylor had a hand in that but
we are inclined to speculate that the
operation never took place and the poem
was an early example of product
placement in a piece of fiction this
marketing tactic may not have worked
after all as it appears that taylor was
in dire financial straits while in
london he was forced to pawn that very
portuguese cross he had sported so
proudly and a notice published in the
same year stated that a certain flaring
itinerant oculist has run from his bail
this is to acquaint him that if he does
not make immediate satisfaction to his
son his name will be published and a
reward for taking him he also left his
wife in distress to whom he has been
married between 30 and 40 years that's
right despite a grueling schedule of
travels and eye operations taylor had
found the time to marry and sire a son
john jr who wasn't exactly happy about
his dad's spending sprees in 1761 john
junior wrote that he had to financially
support his mother as for john cena he
was reported in a list of fugitives for
debt and beyond the seas
[Music]
little is known of taylor's later years
apparently in an ironic twist of fate
his own vision had started to decline
leading to more botched operations in
1769 he established a practice in prague
but the decline was irreversible he was
given an advice to leave by authorities
with a ban on performing eye surgery in
the habsburg territories after years of
disappointments it was time for the
curtains to close or the eyelids to shut
if you like the exact circumstances of
chevalier john taylor's death are
unknown according to musician charles
bernie the two met in rome for dinner in
november 1770. the oculus died there a
few days later on the 16th according to
other witnesses he died in paris several
london papers reported that taylor had
died in july 1772 to quote having given
sight to many thousands the celebrated
chevalier taylor lately died blind at a
very advanced age in a convent a prague
it's tempting to dismiss taylor's death
as the fitting end to a career of
quakery in a stroke of poetic justice
the energetic narcissistic extravagant
restorer of psy died old alone
presumably broke and completely blind
but let's not judge him too soon as a
complete quack nor merely as the man who
blinded and possibly killed bach unlike
other swindling healers of the era
taylor had actually studied medicine and
reportedly quite well while his failures
rather than triumphs have stood the test
of time his success rate was no
different than that of other oculists in
the 1700s medical science at the time
was simply not advanced enough to cure
every disease of the eye and there is at
least one recorded case of a patient
william smythe who feigned blindness
after being treated by taylor to avoid
paying his fees more importantly the
chevalier left behind a corpus of
medical literature which is still
considered valid by ophthalmologists in
the 21st century for example they
developed the first correct diagram of
semi-decussation this is the divergence
of optic nerve fibers he was also the
first oculus to correctly describe how
cataracts occur in the crystalline humor
the fluid-like substance in the lens of
the eye and he may have been the first
to successfully treat strabismus finally
taylor perfected the new procedure of
optical iridotomy to treat glaucoma and
author the first pictorial atlas of eye
diseases perhaps his career can be best
summarized by the judgment bestowed on
him by the already quoted george coates
in professional matters his knowledge
was good he was a shrewd observer and
not without original ideas but his
actual practice was deeply tainted with
the dishonest arts of the quack many
elements go to the formation of the
complete charlatan bombast effrontery
dishonesty ignorance all these qualities
taylor showed imperfection except
ignorance and this is his chief
condemnation